one in five of us is at risk of getting
liver disease
the British liver trust wants to see
universal screening introduced they say
the number of people dying from the
disease is now four hundred times higher
than forty years ago
Charlotte low-mass reports as a chef at
a michdan starred restaurant Alexei Gore
Tia likes to taste each dish before it's
served that was until he found out that
trying a little bit of everything was
enough to severely damage his health in
October 2010 he was diagnosed with liver
disease I thought there was something
wrong so interested doctor and and and
she was very surprised to see that I
have a liver problem and I was very
surprised too because what she described
was something that will happen to
someone who eat really a lot of drink a
lot which wasn't my case a lot in terms
of drinking but definitely in terms of
eating I didn't think I was overeating
in many areas of healthcare such as
heart disease death rates are going down
with liver disease it's the opposite
death rates have been soaring by four
hundred percent since nineteen seventy
is now the third most common cause of
early death among working aged people
health campaigners are calling for the
government to act and introduce liver
screening for everyone that's why MP
Luciana Berger put her liver to the test
on camera she joined a group of cross
party MPs lending support to the British
liver trust so I've just had my liver
tested and I'm delighted to find out
that I do have a healthy liver count
well finding out about liver disease
early actually saves the money to the
National Health Service because the
longer you wait and the longer and
people take to be diagnosed the higher
the cost can be people with liver
disease often don't show any symptoms
medical experts say Universal screening
will lead to earlier detection screening
would make a huge difference
my youngest patient with liver cirrhosis
secondary to obesity age 17 if she had
been screened earlier but pause she was
obese this will have been picked up way
before she became cirrhotic many people
associate liver disease with alcohol but
the most common cause is obesity and
also hepatitis
with better detection and raised
awareness experts hope patients will be
able to get help before it's too late
Charlotte Lomas Sky News